what's going on guys my name is David
sandwich from welcome back to the
channel today we're gonna be talking
about dollars and Donuts that's right
we're using Donuts as a metaphor for
your financial needs to start up a brand
new company or online business in 2019
let's play the intro and get right into
it so as you can see we have four Donuts
and each one of them represents a
different section of the financial needs
you're going to require obviously
everybody's business is going to be
different so I'm using these donuts as a
percentage based figure to you they can
represent a hundred dollars maybe a
thousand maybe even ten thousand dollars
each but everybody's situation is
different so the donuts are just a
percentage figure interpret how you wish
so you might be thinking yes I've got
four donuts to start a company but what
you don't realize is those four donuts
are gonna go really really quickly let's
break it down
donut 1 so donut 1 is going to be your
products and your services this is how
much it's gonna cost you to bring those
products into the country and before you
know it
donut one's gone and you've only got
three doughnuts left now we do three
donuts that are left you're gonna be
thinking I've still got plenty of money
to bring this company to life and make
it run well well it depends on the
country that you live in but in
Australia you're going to get taxed for
bringing in products over a thousand
dollars so straight away your brand-new
product and your brand new company that
you've started you're going to lose
another 15% on top of that so that's
another quarter of a donut hmm gone
we're just over two and a half donuts
left in your bank account and a whole
bunch of product probably sitting in
your cupboard it's time to get this
company in front of the people which
means a building a website be marketing
on Facebook Instagram and all social
media platforms and see probably hiring
a whole bunch of consultants like
graphic designers to help you design a
logo and bring your company to life if
you're thinking how much should I spend
to do all this and get all those
products out to customers and make sure
my brand keeps growing well
realistically you're gonna have to spend
another half to a whole doughnut to get
that product out the door now my maths
is right and I've been keeping up with
my own rambling here and not eating too
many donuts you're gonna be left with 1
and 3/4 doughnuts left to keep growing
your company assuming everything's gone
to plan and the last day night you spent
on marketing has gone really well and
helped you sell all those products it's
probably time to do some research and
development now if you're running this
company on your own chances are you
don't need to pay anybody for research
and development because you know what
you want and you know what your
customers are after which is great you
still got plenty of donuts well let's
say your company's growing at a rapid
rate that you can't keep up and you need
to start employing people and hiring
them do this work for you all of a
sudden you're one 3/4 doughnuts from the
four doughnuts you had at the start goes
down to about one and a quarter don't
know if you've made it this far in the
video and you're still thinking David I
don't have four doughnuts to start a
company don't worry that's okay I
started my first company why watches
link in the description if you want to
check it out with only one donor I use
this one doughnut a hundred percent on
products I didn't do any marketing I
didn't do any website building I used it
for products only now yes it took me a
lot longer to be able to push my company
and make it grow but it is still
possible I'm just giving you guys the
most ideal situation on how to start a
company and the benefits of starting a
company with four donuts is that you
have a few donuts left in your bank
count when everything is up and running
and just in case something goes wrong
before you know it somebody's going to
pull out of a marketing campaign or
products aren't going to sell as well
through Instagram campaign and you're
spending another quarter to half a
doughnut on extra marketing and extra
administration fees for no reason that
you've completely unplanned for okay so
now we're down to the bottom of the
barrel the last little lonely donut
we've covered everything we've covered
product to covered marketing we've
covered the website design and building
so why do we have one
left in our little metaphor here well
obviously if you're growing a company
you wanted to keep growing
you can't bowl of a sudden run out of
products and have nothing on your
website to sell that's why the last
donut is the annexed collection it's the
next product that you're about to
release and remember it is start it took
us one whole donut to start our first
product so it's going to take us another
whole donut to launch our second product
and that's all for today guys we're all
out of donut and the metaphors over
hopefully this has helped you understand
how much of a financial investment
you're gonna need to make to start your
very first company if you like this
video make sure you smash that subscribe
button
20:19 style and I'll see you in the next
one